alright so to get started showing you
some of the performance techniques and
chrome devtools I want you to load up
the dev tools bar and also check out
this great html5 game called bio lab
disaster now I love this game it's made
with a fantastic framework called impact
jazz and happens to be a lot of the
motivation on how we did the grits
crowed base back in the other course now
let's take a look at what we have here
when we talk about performance we always
talk about three pillars of performance
Network render and compute what we're
going to talk about today first is the
network pillar in order to get an
understanding of how your web
application is loading what resources
are coming down to the wire and how long
it's taking the first thing you need to
do is open up the network tab in chrome
devtools this is a fantastic gem and
treasure trove of information because
basically this actually records every
request that your web application is
making to the server and listed here
with a lot of very valid information for
example you can see what type it is the
status of the request the content how
long it took to get it and when it came
in in the overall request structure of
your entire loading sequence now we
could spend an entire Udacity course
actually going into the nuances of this
tool and how to use it but instead I
want to focus on a couple key things
first off when you're talking about
loading web applications on mobile
devices there's two things you need to
worry about the first is how many
requests you're actually making so for
instance if you scroll down for play
BioLab com you can actually see there's
a lot of assets that are being loaded
here right every time your phone has to
grab one of these assets off the
internet a lot of things occur but most
importantly is it takes time away from
loading your application mainly because
the medium to retrieve the data is a
little bit slower than just loading it's
a off the memory or off of the disk now
the second thing you need to be
concerned about is actually the size of
the content that you're trying to load
so if you go over here to the size
button and you actually click on it
twice it's actually going to sort all of
the assets that you requested by their
size now notice right here this top one
actually has two megabytes now look
that's a single augs i'll of course
that's going to be music but basically
that's too
megabytes that has to be downloaded
before this web application can be
played now did you know that according
to HTTP archive the average website size
is only 1.1 megabytes so already this
single asset is larger than most of the
web sites on the web listen that's not
going to help you load this on your
mobile device any faster so by sorting
it by size you can get a great sense of
what assets you have what sizes they are
and see the relative proportion on how
long it takes those assets to actually
be loaded